hello rejects Greg here John here so
Greg and John have had a very long day
we went on hit or miss movies channel
that was about an hour away from us and
then we were there for a couple hours
like three or four hours and then we
immediately went to bloom house gotta
shake hands of Bill Mosley and then now
we've finally got it back and it's Joe
Lynch village yeah you took a picture do
you took a picture of my shirt it was
awesome after hours and hours in traffic
we're gonna watch the Duggar trailer
yeah finally beginning a lot of requests
to watch this throughout the day
Christopher Nolan who psy know about
Dunkirk is that it was a battle in
France during World War two there are
Tom Hardy movies them Warner Brothers
guaranteed no monetization
[Music]
Oh
the enemy tanks have stopped why my
waste precious tanks when they can pick
us off on the air like a fish in a
barrel
there are 400,000 men on this Beach
Tahoe [ __ ]
[Music]
what's going on there
background
[Music]
ha good summer fun
what are you going home Kirk
there's no hiding from this Sun we have
a job to do
vo there was a hope is a weapon
[Music]
there is
[Music]
you can practically see it from here
what oh boy oh it's been a while since
I've seen a war film I saw hacksaw Ridge
I know I had a month ago I was not that
blown away by the trailer what I don't
know it doesn't really it seems kind of
conventional I don't know how to put it
like this feels like a cinematic war
movie it there seems to be a lack I mean
it's just one tre it's a two minute
trailer out of I'm sure a Nolan War epic
but it turns up to our man who's gonna
end like a lot of bits on IMAX as well
it feels very much like a movie to me
and for some reason when I go to like
watch war films I'm looking for more of
a stronger sense of realism I don't know
how to quite put it into words I was
expecting to be like really blown away
or something but this this kind of just
looks like it looks conventional like a
conventional World War Two flick in a
lot of ways I don't know how much you
can change the stylistic underpinnings
of a World War 2 movie I feel like this
is a genre unless you're gonna go
Tarantino about it even Tarantino
restrained at least a little bit in some
ways for Inglourious Basterds this to me
is definitely a more grounded more
restrained looking Christopher Nolan
film but I at this point in his career I
kind of like that he's going in that
direction because ever since he got
Batman Begins it's been a steady
escalation upwards it's every movies
gotten bigger and more crazy we had the
three Dark Knight films then we had this
crazy sci-fi thing with Inception then
we had the [ __ ] universe with an
interstellar and so like for me I'm
excited to see him come and do a world
war two epic because this is a genre
that I feel like each filmmaker leaves a
stamp on like world war ii movies all
feel like they belong on the same shelf
to me for the most part every single one
I've seen every war movie from that era
I feel like every filmmaker who touches
it brings something to it so I'm
interested to see what his take on World
War 2 looks like because it is gonna be
more restrained than a lot of his stuff
and the thing of
this trailers I get the sense like
something tells me that young guy is
probably gonna be our main protagonist
because even though this is Tom Hardy
move you feel like that's a little
misleading for a Nolan movie because
they're always ensemble pieces you know
like we're gonna get to know a little
bit of Tom Hardy Cillian Murphy I'm sure
we'll get to know Kenneth Branagh like
we'll see the war from all these
different guys perspectives I feel like
this is a swing back to what I liked
about Nolan in terms of storytelling and
character stuff I hope all I'm getting
from this trailers is gonna be a world
war 2 movie where you're gonna be in it
with them you're gonna live kind of an
approximation of of these situations
that they were in and what life I get
the sense that this will be a little
more realistic it seems like a really
realistic I feel like yeah a more toned
down Nolan film but I don't know I guess
I was expecting more in some capacity
I'm almost happy that it's not crazy cuz
that was my problem with interstellar is
like sometimes it reaches a bit too far
for me for my tastes and so this is like
okay seeing him come back and doing you
know something more restrained now I
guess exciting because this is a movie
that like yeah the trailer is probably
not gonna be crazy but I feel like this
is a movie where the subtleties of
actually being there and and really
getting into it could be incredible
because this is the first and we're
gonna see this on IMX which is more of a
form thing and not so much a story thing
I know from experience I've found lots
to like about each one of his movies and
I know from experience that those IMAX
sequences are probably gonna be enormous
incredible you know I'm just watch the
trailer I just watch the trailer again
watching the trailer again I I did
notice a lot more in the framing and the
shots and there's some great great shots
in this still and you can tell I got a
lot of people like you know there's a
lot of attention to detail a lot of
these framings you know no one does
practical as much as possible and that's
always at least impressive from what I
understand the Battle of Dunkirk is such
a vital part to world war two and yeah
and and so I know how alone telling a
dunker extort could be very important
and and necessary and worth everyone's
time with that being said though just
from this only two-minute brief glimpse
into this movie it looks like a lot of
other war movies to me and it does it
kind of feels more like it's going to be
Nolan's war
action-movie than war epic of terms of
like emotion and story I don't get
action movie more than epic in this I
mean I get the sense that there will be
battle and it will be violent I have a
feeling I was like thirty I'm in five I
feel like I feel like I'm gonna like the
movie a lot more than this trailer
though I can tell you that much does he
cut his own trailers I don't know or
something cuz his trailers always have a
certain signature to them it seems like
as well even the teaser that they showed
with just the guys on the boat like yeah
like that seemed like a very Nolan II
teasers like you can surmise a lot about
this movie you know you can guess based
on previous experience cuz that's the
thing it's two minutes and it's moving
along fast dunker teaser I really loved
because I was like taking a moment out
of a scene yeah I found that incredibly
effective
the teaser of that scene had more of an
emotional like rawness to it than any of
this trailer to me and I guess that's
what's just what's missing for me is
this this trailer makes it feel more
like a summer war movie did a lot of
ways to me it does it see it doesn't
feel like it's gonna be heavy or
impactful enough to have fallen into
like a november/december release and it
might not be a nice like trailer to me
they might have just made him summer cuz
it's [ __ ] Christopher Nolan you know
yeah I'm curious about that too is maybe
like maybe people more people will see
this you know because they know it's you
yeah cuz he seems to be the guy right
now who can push a blockbuster out of
anything money have a much higher
proportions out of anything I'm curious
too
cuz cuz I mean Nolan is I think he's
like a master filmmaker in a lot of ways
I've heard various arguments over the
subtext in several of his films and a
lot of people think that at least even
though he's intelligent he could be more
refined or more intelligent or he could
tie up some of his metaphors better I
get that complaint of maybe it will be
more of a physical experience maybe will
be really breathtaking to see and
visceral to experience but maybe not so
deep in terms of human substance that's
what this trailer it had me concerned
about my point though is I think I'm
gonna be completely wrong yeah like I
don't actually believe the movie will
turn out that way like I said it's it's
really gonna be a two and a half hour
probably two hour really three
I want to be surprised it was like a
three-hour epic yeah it's you know Nolan
has the capability to do that now I'm
pretty sure I will be like yeah that was
just a trailer like I thought okay so
yeah this this to me especially having
seen twice now it's like it does seem
like it's got one of every kind of
moment like they're a bunch of okay
here's a really striking
you know breathtaking image okay the
locked on like the door sliding shut
like yeah you know here's you know a
very intimate moment with the men here's
something weird like that thing where he
walks into the water
yeah a cannon I thought those kind of
ran away like I'm like that's a weird
kind of one of those strange war movie
moments like this has a lot of moments
and yeah just not much context for any
of them aside from the history but we
don't know who the characters are
specifically you know we don't see Anna
and I feel like with a true war story
that I would want that in the trip I
know Nolan's films where his trailers
they don't really give you a lot of what
I'm asking for to see which is like the
plot in store you know I go with this
look like I know what this movie's gonna
look like and I know what the tones
gonna be I don't know anything
yeah and I would like to see but I
wouldn't mind seeing some of that and
like if they do another trailer which of
course they will like I said that's just
my thoughts about the trailer I'm more
than positive I'm going to be completely
wrong when I see the actual piece maybe
they left a lot of the story out of this
trailer because they want people to
actively go in research history yeah on
the comments say that's very
underwhelming and I don't I don't know
about that because I I feel like the
trailer has to match its film I feel
like we're used to getting mind-blowing
[ __ ] from Christopher Nolan and yeah
we're used to going oh [ __ ] especially
after his trailers and like I don't
think this is the kind of a movie that
you can exactly do that with but it is a
genre that I would love to see
Christopher Nolan yeah I mean don't get
me wrong this feels very like
atmospheric yeah you know and I like
that and I'm sure I'm sure tone and
visual flair will be there and you know
why like I'd like all of his films
hasn't been one Nolan film I haven't
liked yeah I always always more more on
the liking side even if some of even if
I'm something is kind of debatable for
me I still tend to like it a lot you
know I'm still walking out going like
there's some
there are some things that are gonna
stick with me and there's some moment
like I've never seen one of his films
where there hasn't been some moment
aliens yeah exactly
even interstellar like recently like has
some moments that I think are incredible
still yeah he isn't on tour and I do
like that that he's doing what he does
I'm sure this film will feature that and
all he doesn't like to give away his
best stuff in the trailers sorry Anna
that is imagine that imagine that who
does who does that I thought she was
with you I thought I supposed to shoot
stuff all right guys would you think in
a dunker trailer were you a little
underwhelmed were you super high and
positive about it put your clothes like
that [ __ ] I'm gonna get my [ __ ]
opinion everyone must know call the
government [ __ ] you rejects room I'm not
loving it the way I love it
[ __ ] you Greg I'm gonna get a tattooed
on my faces send you a picture every day
today the chalak an subscribe to day
accept it his reasons Jerry Instagram
and Twitter facebook.com slash the real
rejects and bloom houses social media
he's in charge of that [ __ ] as well
shout out to crystal crystal is a
subscriber and she's a lovely lovely
lady a beautiful Puerto Rican lady
crystals a fan of the channel and I told
her I'd give her a proper shout out one
of these days alright so here's your
proper shout out for opera shout outs
crystal you stay beautiful on the inside
and the outside and on the middle the
outside is the barriers in between
sometimes make me most men might
consider that most important this guy
though maybe lean a little bit more
towards most important sure no no no
women points no stay on the inside
beautiful you can get fat and ugly on
the outside all you want but as long as
you're beautiful on the inside you gotta
be okay crystal I think you should feel
good about both